so are we in the uh are we in the world
where it's Bonnaroo rumors season yet
are we in rumor
chatter season
I think it started close can someone
tell me who the the rumored uh
Headliners are do we have anything like
that yet
if there's any big rumors or not oh yeah
okay okay great we were hoping you'd
tell us we've got to be rage right rage
yeah well I mean I don't know why not
I've made my demands demands that's
right I told everybody on the show last
week that the reason you were not around
was because you were on a hunger strike
that you hadn't
you hadn't eaten red meat since uh you
made your demand so for the year is yes
right I've been making demands for 13
years that's right um I uh so I did I
did find out who the Saturday headliner
is and I'm pretty sure the Friday late
night was told to me as well they don't
know if it was definitely Friday uh late
night or if it's The Closer on Friday or
on Sunday rather so I don't know and and
I don't necessarily feel the most conf
or comfortable uh saying it out loud
just yet but
um boy if that rumor mill was going
around we really could make that a lot
easier this conversation
um but I'll just put it this way uh the
Saturday headliner is
gonna be massive
um and then the Friday late night is
everything that we've wanted for years
or at least berries wanted for years uh
and it's it's a perfect perfect
combination and these two bands alone I
think make um uh the Bonnaroo faithful
very very very happy yeah good yeah I'm
excited from what you told me
um
I also wanted to say I had some some
folks reach out uh we're I'm going to
talk next week with some folks with uh
Live Nation and uh they have some some
prizes some plans they're working on and
we're gonna hopefully set up a podcast
so okay looking forward to uh surprises
as in as in like campsite adjustments
I'm not exactly sure it was very it was
very short note just basically can we
talk next week about some things we've
got in the works and uh and perhaps uh
do a podcast so okay I was thrilled that
they reached out and uh let's talk about
it yeah I'm I'm very excited about it so
I hate to you know tease like that and
but I don't know that any more than that
yet